this week we've got Google van hmm
famous suspect and Oreo expansion Oh
Oreos are kind of good but let's start
from the Google then Google bad what are
they banning they are banned in China
it's an internal ban no wigs allowed
wait you can't search for certain things
yeah you can't use Safari you can't tell
people what's going on with YouTube to
help their YouTube channels yeah you
can't complain about the algorithm no so
the internal ban that they have it they
will no longer allow the f-word in
internal like in company documents and
URLs or any references to sex wait that
four dozen Facebook or effort as an all
[ __ ] oh we got D mom attack which one so
before they could say [ __ ] yeah before
they use the word [ __ ] internal
document oh [ __ ]
shortened URLs that lead to something
else but it could be like here's a
[ __ ] email yeah another Kent damn
that's a quad yeah that is a really cool
company this is your specific cuz I
thought that was like God yeah in a
professional environment you're not
really supposed to write talk to each
other well you can bring your dogs you
have a snack section you can play a ping
pong that's here yeah that's why I
thought there F word was Facebook cuz
when I talk to friends that work at
Reebok Toby can't say the n-word yeah
one way no no Mikey I would be any
company should say the n-word way Google
and Facebook don't [ __ ] know there
because I was trying to take over each
other my facebook videos on tape over
YouTube let's always trying to like what
I thought it was Google what did you try
to do with this no Google owns YouTube
oh those gonna fight oh I remember we
were working with the group and they're
being sponsored by whether it was Pepsi
or coke I forgot but they had to get the
competitors products out because they're
like a rap is coming and then there
rushon to [ __ ] grab all the coke
products and hide them oh my god yeah
you're like hide your coke no not that
coke look I'll go meet that one out that
one's okay so this comes four months
after management issued a new employee
behavior guidelines so some people in
this company are like man well this well
some people are like well about time you
know we should be a little bit more
professional like a huge company and
they just treat it like post dorm life
style kind of company and then other
people are like oh those are those
uppity [ __ ] yeah uppity [ __ ] and
then other people are like man but this
is Google like right known for this [ __ ]
like ping pong tables in the office kind
of [ __ ] can they say [ __ ] I don't know
but like why [ __ ] you know like why just
that one specific word I mean that's
what's also what stuff it's like no
matter what move you make you can never
make everyone happy
right what's anything that's why you
should just let people make their own
choices and then if everyone's like that
guy's an [ __ ] then you fire him but
like most people don't abuse the choices
they don't understand the company
culture and you should get rid of them
exactly I guess they're changing the
company culture so there's such a huge
company now but they've been a huge
company no they know they're a huge
company maybe it just depends on who's
running the company at that time cuz
like the company culture can change
depending on who's like the CEO at the
time or whatever - cuz they'll have
their own little things they want to do
kind of like that lady that's running
YouTube right now but I'm not gonna say
anything oh yeah we won't say can't say
the name
you guys can google it but you can do
who's running YouTube right now why
things are changing but anyways Sandra
Bullock oh we are actually even talking
about earlier date oh we are okay it's
gonna be really hard to be unbiased you
know people with personal and political
agendas in like they want to you know do
all that stuff on the platform and
control everything to to make you know
to make it fit their [ __ ] you know I
don't know I'm not naming any names I'm
just saying like that's why YouTube's
the way that it is and people that don't
support their own creators and want to
bring in all the time
stars into it and push all the old
creators out we're gonna talk about it
later
eight okay I'm not naming any names
either but I think we're talking about
the same person right sounds are books
now you want an online well we'll find
out later but right now we're still uh
talking about Google banning the [ __ ]
word so we're saving it sound like so
intense I know I'm like oh they should
be panties three [ __ ] word I be
[ __ ] every Instagram caption yeah and
then never get brand deals again
Instagram is Facebook Instagram is
Facebook my let you say [ __ ] okay but
you're not monetized on Facebook anyway
so it doesn't matter
yeah in a month I am now I made four
cents for 10,000 views they gave me four
cents Wow Wow
it might be seventeen cents now oh [ __ ]
huh unify us dinner
maybe but yeah save up for dinner TJ
okay save up for a big one taco you know
how much our forces you get a taco with
just onions and cilantro myself it's
just a tortilla what if she said what
onions and cilantro no me it's like the
part with the dot like speck all right
next story so there was this person that
the police were looking for in the UK
and they posted this photo up looking
for the suspect oh I saw this he took
the whole bunch account looks like Ross
David David Schwimmer David Schwimmer
David I mean what is they don't know
Rachel Green Russ what's a dehl our
killer David Schwimmer was like hey man
it wasn't me
that is why Allah good sets a proof that
I was in the New York when this happened
at the time of this incident so it was
not me Danny has a good sense of humor
that's awesome that's crazy
you know what's crazier this duo for me
this dude looks like the young Ross and
yeah now he's like so there's like a
different dimension and then young Ross
is here yeah because the time isn't
linear it's it's like spread splattered
like confetti damn I hope you guys are
watching this hi cuz we just blew your
mind haha i reference i recently watched
a whole bunch of the house on Haunted
Hill I want to watch it I want to watch
it it's so good and that that was a
reference to that cuz it's scary as [ __ ]
and I don't like scary movies
you gotta watch it in the morning of
course you remember that's what we watch
brands about yeah start your day off
watching it then you won't be so expect
to see great like during the day so we
went to the went the Westchester
Winchester home you went there yes in
the daytime and I'm like this is cool
like I can do this cuz I'm with my
friends and then [ __ ] man come nighttime
I'm at my own house now I'm like yeah
you're like what did I bring with me I
can't I can't watch it with the with us
with the Sun out it doesn't feel right
right series with the Sun out and I
ended it with the Sun like you know down
so you just binge watched it and then
because I was in the middle of studying
and then watching that yeah I would
treat myself with like 10 minutes a bit
cool I finished an article pods let me
watch this for like 10-15 minutes hello
I can't watch like that and then um so I
ended up last night I had a bunch of
nightmares because I'm like oh my god
this is in my head I just keep thinking
dude I had a [ __ ] nightmare or dream
however you want to say that [ __ ] Joe
proposed what wait to God is a nightmare
so it was I know we're side talking but
lockers like he he proposed to me and
your with Jess and then you were like it
was like some [ __ ] Game of Thrones
type tip or it's like we got to preserve
the power so wasn't for love or anything
it was like okay we got to keep barb oh
and gotta make it stronger and then just
was like yeah you guys should do it I
was like this is [ __ ] weird womanís
like an actual episode anybody else of
JK news where I'll tell her to go [ __ ] a
millionaire or something and I was like
we're all on the same team
yeah so like did you say yes or what no
the whole time I was like this is
[ __ ] weird but there was a bunch of
people and he just had like the ring and
and just where everyone was watching the
perfect beat and it just was supporting
it yeah where was bored he had already
proposed and he was somewhere else yeah
like he was I said yes to him obviously
but then I was like I like what we
proposed on the same day yeah I'm like
when you proposed to Jess and then you
were like no it's cuz we got it like
keep the company like we got it we've
got to help it grow and I'm like this is
[ __ ] weird dude you're like sort of
guys go ahead how big the ring in your
mind of marriage kept the company
stronger no no in my dream not my mind
it's just the [ __ ] whatever's going
on in my head you got to do what you got
to do Jay let's go and that's pretty
tight though
what cuz you always wanted a proposal
and two of them she wants me to someone
do it's gotta be a surprise it has to be
maybe like 10 years later you got to do
like I got to forget about you already
forgot you did it you just were like
let's do this [ __ ] or something no Kazak
in the day back in the day I I didn't
think you wanted proposals I didn't know
she wanted a ring or anything like that
hey hey girl we have a whole skin where
he's proposing to you that's a skin
let's make believe Joe that's not real
he was taking a [ __ ] like yeah we should
be that awesome no boys it's not
that's all never she wants like a vlog
which she's getting propose she said no
and she's like behind the scenes like I
don't know what we're going to
you guys know any girls like crying I
will say I didn't want it to be like I
had told Steve oh I wouldn't want you to
do it in like a big grand way I just
want it to be like intimate between the
two of us and like I wouldn't want it to
be filmed and stuff but now that he did
it that way I'm like oh I kind of wish
there was a picture oh yeah now the
whole vlog but like it time we're never
happy yeah girls are not rebels are
never happy I loved the proposals uh
Anna
like we were both sunburned so wouldn't
it looks good hey wait but um but yeah
that was the only required like
requirement or whatever I asked for a
Casey I'm like listen I don't care how
it happens you can do whatever it
doesn't even have to be a real diamond
like you just don't spend that much
money and all I want is video of it
happening because I want to be able to
that was video yeah it was here three
angles during a JK news episode really
what was a fake episode I never aired
imagine surprise Gio this is your sound
did you put the fake one into your blog
look yeah so the whole vlog of him
picking out the ring and then showing
everyone and then it was in that video
so that's cool yeah and then I also post
it on Instagram like a year later okay
got sidetracked here we're talking about
David Schwimmer well there's nothing
else to say it really isn't
this was good this one's better true do
a fake proposal video that Steve made
for his channel I thought that was your
proposal a lot of people did think that
but if you watch it like it was way
after he proposed so I was wearing the
ring by accident in the beginning no
people noticed some people did of course
and I didn't know I forgot but yeah yeah
people like our even our friends even
we're like hey that was crazy and I'm
like you know that was a that was not
real that was a joke you didn't watch
till the end did you cuz I did I was
like wait this isn't real this Gavin it
was a scavenger hunt and it went on
forever
like I it would make me go to the pillow
and then you made me go to the bathroom
or anything if you go to the kitchen the
last one was like let's go to Denny's
and then so n I'm hungover the whole
time I'm hungover and then we go to
Denny's and the waitress is like I'll
give you some more time and he's like at
he loses and then he like oh my god the
ring I like get off or get off the floor
stop this is embarrassing get four and
he's like well will you and I'm like
just just gift before get Danny's yeah
Dennis and then oh man we just didn't
know either so she comes over and she's
like can I take your order now and I was
like he just proposed it's [ __ ] awful
whatever before time and people thought
that was a real all right last story
here so Oreos is coming out with their
most stuffed Oreo never they got a stop
it's called that's aria to me it's like
a huge inside that does live almost
vanilla ice cream that was like a cake
have you had the Oreos imagine biting
[ __ ] dude I have a story about Oreos
I couldn't eat Oreos for ten years when
I was a kid I only like to lick the
cream out of the Sun right so I would
open it and scrape the cream out then my
parents got a Costco membership where
they got like a bunch of Oreos our baby
was at Costco I was like somewhere where
they got in bulk they got a bunch of
6-pack of Oreo packets that they would
put on lunch every day but I was a
latchkey kid so I come home alone and so
I had access to all these Oreos I had
the best idea I'll take a bunch of Oreos
scrape the cream out and roll it into a
ball and they'll just disgust so I took
like 36 Oreos like six packs of signa
way YouTube video it's good to LA I know
right we didn't have YouTube back then
and I was like this is gonna be so good
I just put the whole thing in my mouth
and then I was like and you know it's
like it makes that film on the top and I
couldn't and I tried to swallow it and
then I just threw up and I couldn't eat
Oreos for like ten years after that I
had such a good image of this and you
said like you said that's sorry and I'm
like [ __ ] I don't to try that anymore
like too much like Oreos again I think
the cookie part balances it now yeah you
have to have a boy yeah but when you're
a kid you're like [ __ ] these cookie
program
thankee ports are like always it's stale
and it's like chemically yeah don't know
I like it now yes a bag van I couldn't
eat the whole thing what happened to the
extra I don't know they just put one cuz
it looks like shut the [ __ ] up but it
just SOT it looks like shut that up but
maybe some people get triggered from 2f
so that that too much it's too rough -
to stop the condition they try to put 3s
and still oh yeah cuz it's a lot of
stuff yeah yeah yeah you should be a
marketing well yeah I'm not really a big
Oreo fan I just like the golden Oreos
same all right like a little little ones
you know those at all partying sized
ones I'll put that in milk oh I don't
really like Oreos that much either buddy
it the [ __ ] out of him I don't like the
chocolate cookie what about the cookies
and cream ice cream bomb the Oreo ice
cream is back yep yep yep yep um yeah
I'm more of a fan of like Pepperidge
Farms type cookies
no thank you I like the Milano like big
yeah like Milano I like gourmet ass
cookies or mrs. field looks so good in
the commercials and Milano cookies I
finally tried one although you don't
like did you dip it in milk concern did
you do the mint one or the regular the
dark chocolate the orange one the mint
one I don't like the orange the extra
filling one have you had those uh Toll
House chocolate chip in a bucket I love
those oh yeah and some ice cream if I
can make a sandwich did you ever eat it
straight out of the bucket yes
[ __ ] yeah don't I had a spoonful but I
haven't sat there didn't make your
stomach hurt operator it freaks me out
cuz I'm like it's supposed to be baked
so I'm eating raw [ __ ] oh it's so good
breaks me out but you don't like cookie
dough ice cream never had it
Oh what cuz it makes me really what
freaks we all had eating disorders and
we all had eating desserts I mean like
different types damn [ __ ]
come out I'm okay so so I would like not
eat for a while and then that cold
well anorexia I guess but I wasn't good
at it so like oh I would just go for a
while without eating and then or like I
would eat and then I would run for like
a long time or like go exercise for a
long time I don't know I'm not I'm not
condoning this behavior but I am sick
just like being on the rescue
while four of not eating and then there
was like a bar of cookie dough in the
fridge I hate that whole oh yeah that's
probably what you know Darby's really
bad of it well that's like when it looks
like a big fat sauce yeah I love oh so
it started out I just took a piece and
then I would go back to my room and then
we'll come back out I'm like your body's
like I need food y'all it's craving
sugar you know yeah that's definitely
anything this sort of don't do that
cookie dough very unhealthy sugar
cookies I couldn't ever throw up so I
had to have to just like go to the gym
for five hours and that's all so bad
don't do that I got really skinny
because I was too lazy to eat dude for
Mexicans you can't get skinny or
Allstate they're always saying kick in
Islam buddy says oh my whole life okay
so Phillip you like a little Filipinos
are like oh you're looking at the bok
choy and oh you're soft the bok choy
like oh you can eat all the food huh the
other food and then yeah and then so
then you stop eating and then they're
like why so skinny never
oh yeah you should eat you gotta eat
like that's pretty much any reason every
any minority is like you're always wrong
you're always too fat or too skinny I
got a call to bok choy my entire child
with the hot choy it's chubby that was
my dad still convict a bok choy he's
always like the back I'm a little bite
oh hey Chloe [ __ ] got forever and I'm
like what was cute it is cute I like
what I just got annoying cuz I'm like I
can't gain weight okay
Tiffany I'm crying the biggest tears for
you okay I've been on your end and I'll
tell you that one's easier and you
always like I don't like food you need
to be joy here my back he understand
what you don't get out here he could eat
whatever he wants that's what I used to
think I can't gain weight right but now
you have to hold back hold back from
what eating things you want if you're on
a fat end or like if you can't get
getting there I was so jealous of people
like you that like didn't get wanna eat
the food I just want to eat everything
yeah cuz the only problem is is like is
the body part right like getting gaining
weight but if you're on the other side
not only are you trying to lose weight
and change your body but you also have
to control what you eat
yeah and then you go to a social event
everyone's like having a blast eaten
yeah like maybe it is harder because I
can't really I don't know but it is also
I'm not saying what I had was like a
[ __ ] breeze because I tried to make
myself want to eat the things so you
could fit in try to eat okay so just
quiet okay it was really hard I feel you
and then like doctor always make it to a
saint healthy and exercise and I'm like
it's the same thing it's just hard I'm
playing you like a tiny violin now you
know there's people out there that
really yeah cuz I've talked about my
skinny girl problems in the past and
people are like I know exactly what
you're going through so hang your feet
all right I wish I had that struggle to
go through and relate to
[Laughter]
[Music]